[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au tampon donc là vous
êtes chez moi à l'entreprise signe au
naturel
je m'appelle voir ok j'ai 28 ans et mon
entreprise s'appelle signe naturel elle
a été créée en décembre 2020 pour créer
mon entreprise j'ai l'aide du Tage donc
j'ai suivi avec la boutique de gestion
Sud ainsi naturel en fait c'est une
entreprise qui propose des services à
qui est accès autour de la langue des
signes bébé et de la langue des signes
française donc je propose divers
prestation ça part de cycle d'atelier de
Bessines Niort donc là où je travaille
avec des particuliers ou des
professionnels les crèches exetera ça
parce qu'il parlait formation donc en
langue des signes ou en langue des
signes bébé et aussi je propose aussi
des cours hebdomadaire donc en fait
tomber de cours d'anglais une fois par
semaine en fait mais en langue des
signes du coup pour les enfants et je
vais mettre en place aussi bientôt pour
les adultes les ateliers de langue des
signes bébé sont destinés aux personnes
porteuses de handicap ou non aux parents
aux femmes enceintes et aux enfants la
naissance jusqu'à environ 4 ans les
ateliers donne aux parents on va dire
une base pour qu'il puisse communiquer
avec leurs leurs bébés pendant la
période pris là-bas parce que souvent on
fait face aux pleurs aux cris au
frustrations frustrations parce que ça
fait un petit être donc il a des besoins
et qui n'arrive pas a forcément exprès
c'est un beau tremplin voilà pour
avant d'ouvrir l'entreprise j'ai donc
j'ai fait des études de médecine et je
suis tombée enceinte est la naissance il
m'a dit que mon fils de partir de demain
jusqu'à lundi 21 j'ai décidé en fait à
ce moment-là de l'arrêter mais je me
suis dit que il avait besoin que je sois
là donc j'ai arrêté quand il est rentré
à l'école j'ai commencé à travailler
j'ai travaillé 2 ans en garderie
périscolaire avec l'emploi du temps que
j'avais pour lui et puis tu es souvent
malade c'est compliqué le statut de
salarié ne me convenait pas du tout je
me suis dit il fallait joue mon
entreprise c'est vrai que tout est parti
au niveau de mon fils il avait du mal à
communiquer donc il a commencé à signer
en inventant des signes et je me suis
dit qui t'a autant qu'il le fasse
correctement et j'ai découvert la langue
des signes je me suis fort mais j'ai
aimé ça mais vraiment ça a été vraiment
le déclic je j'ai passé mes formations
j'ai passé mes diplômes moi ce que
j'aimerais pouvoir embaucher m'a
justement des personnes qui sont
porteuses de handicap
malentendante pour qu'elle se dit ou
autre et puis je me dis aussi c'est vrai
que mon fils il participe aux ateliers
beaucoup du coup il aime il aime
vraiment ce qu'il fait et moi j'espère
voilà ce que mon fils si ça lui plaît
bien sûr il y a pas d'obligation pour
avoir un emploi et proposer à connaître
mon handicap c'est pas forcément quelque
chose qui nous voilà
et voilà
bien dans ce signe bien dans sa
communication bien dans son corps de
quoi préparer un adulte heureux épanouie